i had a business owner reach out
yesterday who's doing about 550 000 a
month and they were requiring for us to
become an acquisition.com portfolio
company and the conversation was really
interesting and so i thought i would
share it with you
so we hopped on the call you know within
the first minute or two you know after
saying hey you know how's it going et
cetera um he was like yeah uh you know i
had a bunch of clinics and then covet
hit we took everything to telehealth and
then our profit exploded and it's been
awesome and i was like well that's great
and he's like so what i'm thinking about
doing is um
helping starting a new business uh to
help physicians uh improve their their
medical practices
and i was just like
huh he was like yeah because you know
you did this thing with gym owners and
you kind of licensed your model out i
kind of want to do the same thing with
with with physicians
and i sat there and i was like this is
going to be a really interesting
conversation and so
after him going you know giving his
reasoning behind this i was like well i
have no interest in that business at all
um
and um i was like let me tell you why
i was like first off you want to enter
established marketplace that is
incredibly saturated um the the value
proposition that you have is not based
on like a ton of personal experience
right
you have a handful of examples it's also
not that unique there's plenty of other
people who do this same thing and so you
want to enter a space you've never been
in before have a new acquisition system
a value proposition that's not defined
it's incredibly saturated and there's
nothing new and i was like
i have no interest in this business and
he was like huh and i was like but
what i am more interested in is why
don't you want to take the thing that's
making you 550 000 a month that you grew
in two years
and just take that to five million a
month
like why aren't you doing that
and so he was like well honestly i kind
of got stuck and i didn't know how to
how to grow it from from here
and so it was it was such a nice point
because there was a pause and i could
you could almost like hear him saying it
to himself and hearing him say it out
loud i was like so let me ask you this
if we could go from 550 000 a month to
you know to tripling your your amount of
customers you have and going one and a
half million a month i was like would
you still be interested in doing this
whole medical
thing you know this other thing that you
were talking about earlier with trying
to teach medic physicians and he was
like oh no of course not i would just
want to do this thing and i was like
okay so to be clear let me restate this
because you got stuck in this existing
business you thought the solution would
be i will start another business huh
not a good deductive reasoning pattern
right
and this is and this is obviously a very
smart individual right and i say this
because
all of us right i do this i do this all
the time right and this is going to be
repeated theme because it needs to be
repeated right we need to be reminded
more than we need to be taught that is a
saying that we have in my world and i
will i will pass it on to you guys mosey
nation we need to be reminded more than
we need to be taught do the boring work
repeat successful actions and so
if he's gotten to this point or if
you've gotten to a point in your
business and it has plateaued
the question is has it plateaued because
this is true like i have the only reason
a business should plateau that is
reasonable that is not your fault is
that you have reached the total
addressable market as in you have
saturated the total the total market of
that thing so for example
if you were selling dog food
and every dog within this you know maybe
you saw a specific type of niche of
poodle food right you've gotten you know
70 of poodle owners to buy your food and
you can't grow any more beyond that
right well that would be reasonable but
then you'd obviously just do a different
type of dog right you you'd hop
verticals right so there's not even a
reason but it would be the only
potentially rational reason
would be
that your market has changed so a
different example is a friend of mine
owned a company that does uh newspaper
advertising right so they actually help
newspapers translate their
advertisements into uh digital products
which is pretty cool so they are able to
sell like basically a whole new ad
product to small businesses um who want
to buy ads right which is by the way how
newspapers make money he could not grow
his business because newspapers have
shrunk by 25 year-over-year which is 25
compounding the wrong direction and he's
been in that business for like 10 years
so now the market size is like literally
like five percent of what he used to be
10 years ago and so as a result of that
he was growing at an inverse rate to the
shrinkage of the industry right and so
he got to a point where he couldn't grow
any more than just basically servicing
the ones that are still alive and then
as they fell so did his business right
and so that is the only logical reason
that a business can't plateau that is
not in your control and unless you're
selling your newspapers which you're
probably not the reason is much simpler
which is you just don't know how and
i'll tell you a different story that i
had and then i'll i'll i'll wrap this up
at the end so i was having a different
conversation with a woman
who was doing i think four million
dollars a year and she was selling uh
info products that were weight loss like
weight loss info products so like
programs and ebooks and things like that
which is cool right she's a big
following all that kind of stuff
and
we got i went i did a podcast with her
and uh after we got off the podcast she
was like yeah so these are my plans i'm
gonna be doing like an apparel line and
a supplement line and uh cream line and
or whatever right
and i just kind of sat there and i was
like
well i think that's a terrible idea she
was like she just looked at me crosstalk
she's like what i was like yeah i think
it's a terrible idea and she was like
oh and i was like why don't you just
take the thing that's making you 4
million and make it make you 10 million
dollars
when you do that
and the and the answer is the same as
the first answer i just don't know how
and i was like right well why don't we
solve that problem
and then not create a new business why
don't we just put all of our effort in
solving that problem and so i'm a big
believer and this is the the piece that
i want to share with you mostly nation
is that i'm a big believer in the theory
of constraints which means that a system
will grow until it is constrained right
it has a constraint and then once you
remove the constraint it'll continue to
grow right until it reaches another
constraint and so
most people are always curious or many
people ask me hey alex how did you
achieve quote so much in quote such
little time or at such a young age and i
say all that in quotes because so much
could be and young age whatever but i'm
saying i'm just i'm paraphrasing all
right
and i think that um
one of the things that we have done well
is prioritizing what problems to solve
and that is understanding the
prioritization of problems
and realizing that there is really only
typically one or two things that are
constraining our growth and by
definition there'd really only be one
thing that's the constraint until we
reach another thing that might be
beginning to constrain us but isn't the
true constraint yet i'll tell you a
third story so i had a conversation with
a young business owner who was doing
about 150 000 a month within you know a
little bit of time i was able to see
that the issue that he had was that he
hadn't scaled a sales team right that
was the issues that he couldn't scale
sales and we had there was a zillion
things that he could do to improve his
business he couldn't increase his
lifetime gross profit he could change
his price his pricing model i think
there were some things on his messaging
that were off at the end of the day the
thing that he hadn't done was that he
hadn't scaled a sales team and so we
ended up circling back two weeks later
and he was like hey you know um i want
to know how i can like get the most out
of this this phone call with you i was
like well have you have you scaled the
sales team yet he was like no i was like
well then we don't really have anything
to talk about
because there's nothing else that
matters right now besides this
and it took like two or three
reinforcements of that message until he
was like you're really not going to tell
anything else i was like no because it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter that's not the
constraint right now sure you could
improve your pricing sure you could do
these other things but the thing that is
stopping this business from growing is
that you do not have a skilled sales
team and you don't have that skill so
let's phrase the deficiency as a
question which is how do i learn how to
recruit manage and and and train a sales
team and to the first business owner the
question that i said who was doing the
550 a month was during the clinics it's
like the question is how do i scale
acquisition and he had uh he had a
product that was um it's not allowed to
be marketed on um
on on facebook and things like that so
he had to do alternative methods and i
was like so the question is how do i
acquire more customers than i already am
from a different channel that i'm
allowed to
when we phrase the questions like that
then they become problems that we can
solve right rather than i don't know
what to do therefore i will just start
another business which
so many times is the is the
entrepreneurial solution and it's
because it feels good and we think that
somehow when we start another business
it's going to somehow grow but the
reality is and this is what i have found
over and over again is that the
businesses will grow to the level of
incompetence of the entrepreneur so if
you're a 4 million entrepreneur the next
business will be a 4 million business
doesn't matter what it is because that
is your level that is your skill set
right that is those that is that is
dictated or predicated by your beliefs
your traits and your skills
and unless you change one of those
things when you start the next business
you will be capped at that and the other
reality is that how many ceos of
publicly traded companies do you know
that rc's are two companies ceos not
founders elon musk is the only is the
only exception but he's the founder he's
not the one who's running he's not the
operator of those companies all right
there's literally only one right and
he's also a genius and literally like
the smartest human being alive
but most of us are not elon musk we're
if we're on youtube right now we're
probably both not elon musk all right
maybe we can agree on that all right and
so the point of this is that you can't
be ceo of two things it's hard enough to
be in one business business alone is
hard enough right why make it more
difficult and three times as complex by
by adding more variables in and so i
think what most business owners most
entrepreneurs can do right now is simply
ask the question and this is usually
what i'll start any conversation that i
have with an entrepreneur who's reaching
out for something right or one of the
portfolio company ceos is i'll just ask
the question which is
whatever the run rate is at the moment
let's say it's a million dollars a month
i'm like what's stopping us from being
at 5 million a month
what's stopping us
and until we can clearly answer that
question
there's nothing else we need to do and
when we ask better questions we get
better answers why am i not growing is
different than why am i not doing an
extra million dollars a month
what is stopping us from doing that and
if we can get crystal clear on that then
we can find the constraint and then we
can remove the constraint because we can
put all of our effort towards that
singular problem and that in my opinion
is how you scale companies quickly is it
appears fast from the outside but from
the inside it feels manageable and clear
because we're all focused on the one
problem that we're solving at this
moment which might be in the beginning
we need to increase our sales team and
then once we've increased our sales team
we might say hey you know we've
increased the sales team but they're not
all performing the same level so it's
like okay we need to have better
onboarding and training for the sales
team okay we need to do that okay that's
the next problem that we solve we have
consistency in this process okay now
we're doing that but now we're not
getting enough leads okay now we'll put
all of our focus here right and so each
time there's going to be a constraint
and we just have to focus our attention
towards the constraint and then in so
doing we will de-bottleneck and we will
naturally grow to the next level and so
that has been one of the more valuable
lessons that i've had and i i will tell
you that there are a lot of
entrepreneurs who are listening to this
you right now it might be you so i might
be talking to you right now is that you
think that you need to start another
business or another product line because
you're stuck at a current level and
somehow think that this new product line
or new business is going to solve the
problem and it is not so if you like
this mother nation my name is alex from
rosie i own acquisition.com you can go
there for free trainings all free no
opt-in required etc hit subscribe if you
liked it and i'll see you guys next
video bye